voilà le compteur est là ok c'est devenu
une habitude pour les propriétaires de
joigny avant de louer il faut accueillir
un agent de la mairie
il veille à contrôler la salubrité de
logements on regarde s'il ya des fuites
les évacuations les ventilations s'il ya
de l'humidité dans le logement
là c'est vraiment les points qui
pourraient faire qu'on soit sur un
logement insalubre une demi-heure
d'inspection et des critères très précis
pour obtenir ce qu'on appelle un permis
de louer au moins y'a pas de soucis en
cas de refus le logement ne pourra pas
être loué avant que les travaux ne
soient réalisés une première pour cette
propriétaire avec son centre ville
ancien le parc immobilier de la ville
vieilli parfois très mal et les
propriétaires ne font pas les travaux
nécessaires car souvent trop coûteux
pour la mairie ce permis de louer est
donc un moyen de lutter contre l'habitat
indigne ça touche pas par exemple les
bailleurs sociaux eux les bailleurs
sociaux ont une éthique de valeurs
sociales dont qu'ils offrent une qualité
c'est plus les bailleurs privés
moi je ne suis pas en bagarre contre les
bailleurs privés
je suis en bagarre contre les marchands
de sommeil mais que faire dans les cas
les plus extrêmes lorsque le bâtiment
est dit en péril qu'il menace de
s'effondrer
le propriétaire s'il ne fait pas les
travaux va voir la commune qui au regard
de la loi doit se substituer à lui et
faire les travaux à sa place c'est ce
qu'on appelle la procédure des travaux
d'office
la difficulté pour les communes et
évidemment les plus petites communes
c'est qu'elle n'a pas effectivement les
moyens financiers pour pouvoir avancer
l'argent en tout dans le département de
l'yonne 8% des logements sont considérés
comme indignes
le taux le plus important de la région
bourgogne franche comté